foreign
[Music]
first of all I would like to thank the
organizer of this cell biology virtual
event for the opportunity to present my
work here today that has been focused on
the engineering of optogenetic tools for
the manipulation of protein localization
and signaling at the intracellular level
and in particularly at organic contact
sites
I would like to start my talk today
highlighting the importance of having a
tool to precisely control protein
localization at a sub cellular level why
do we need such tool the answer is very
simple the physiological function of
proteins within cells is critically
dependent upon their sub cellular
distribution and local regulation
therefore if you want to really
understand the role of enzymes inside of
a cells we need to be able to
redistribute this protein inside of the
intracellular milia with the same type
of spatial and temporal Precision
however how can we localize the activity
of a protein in a confined portion of a
Solar sub-compartment
how can we deliver a protein to a single
intracellular organelle and even more
how can we temporarily control the
duration of its activity in the area of
Interest
in the afternoon to address these
questions we look into the methods that
would enable us to manipulate protein
expression and localization
genetic manipulations like RNA
interference strategies or genome
editing strategies are extremely
powerful tools however the occur on a
relatively slow time scales relative to
protein dynamics of intracellular
signaling networks and any
post-translational physiological process
and the lack of spatial control and
intracellular level
chemical inducible memorization tools
like those based on fkbp12 or its
interacting partner frb in the presence
of rapamycin and analogues are extremely
versatile tool for the acute control of
protein recruitment intracellular
compartments but also in this case the
lack of spatial control at the level of
subcellular compartments
while light inducible demorization tools
are perfect tools for this purpose
because they enable protein perturbation
on a time scale consistent with the
reversibility of intracellular reaction
and with very high special precision
so during my talk today I will first
discuss how we can use optogenetic tool
for to control protein demorization in
subcellular levels and then I will
introduce our recently engineered
enhanced magnet system as a powerful
tool for this type of perturbation and
then I will show you some of the
applications that we develop using this
emac system in cell biology
so Optical photo switches are a powerful
class of tools that enable to control
protein demorization with light and the
basics of these tools is production
between two proteins or domains or at
least one of the two protein is a
photoreceptor that upon light radiation
undergoes a conformational change and in
this conformation combines with
interactive partner the duration of the
interaction between the two proteins
depends on three main factors the switch
on kinetic the duration of the photo
stimulation and the switch of kinetic
that defined for how long the two
protein can interact one to each other
when the excitation light has been
withdrawn from the system
this slide briefly summarizes some of
the most widely used Optical
heterodomerization system used in cell
biology so far as you can see here they
can be broadly classified in blue light
dependent system or red and Nerium
fluoride dependent systems according to
the wavelengths of light that are used
to activate or inactivate the
photoreceptor
while using red and Eerie fluoride light
dependencies then we can confine protein
demorization is more fraction of the
cell by contemporarily irradiating with
activating light the region of Interest
inside of the cells and with
inactivating light the remaining portion
of the cell
uh with the blue light dependent system
we don't have these Advantage however we
can use of the microscope setup that are
more simple and easily available in
every department so I started my work
asking how can we specially confine the
medication without the possibility to
control photoreceptor deactivation
exactly using blue light dependent
system
and I decided to test the capability of
these tools to confine protein
demorization in fraction of subcellular
organelles using the endoplasmic
reticulum as my test bed and I chose
this organelle because it's a very broad
intracellular compartments that span the
whole cell and we're intrinsic membrane
protein are extremely multi
in all my experiments I expressed the
two components of its temerization pair
in the same configuration so one of the
components is expressed on the outer
membrane of the endoplasmic reticulum
and I will call this molecule bait while
the other protein is soluble in the
cytosol infused of fluorescent protein
that enables me to visualize this report
and during my Imaging experiments and I
will call this molecule prey there are
three main factors that are critical in
the capability to confine protein
demorization with these tools and which
I would like you to pay attention during
the next part of my talk first of all
the location of the photoreceptor in the
demolition pair so whether it's soluble
or a tether to the membrane of the
intracellular compartment of Interest
the switch on end of kinetics and the
capability to localize the available
peripheral interaction in the area of
Interest
the first pair that I tested for this
application is the one based on the
photoreceptor crytochron 2 ncb1
overabidopsy stalliana
system is characterized by a very
relatively faster switch of sweets on
kinetic with another flag over about
four seconds and a relatively slow speed
of kinetic with an half-life of about 5
minutes
and with the Indies this system I tested
the pair where the CB1 protein is
expressed on the membrane of the
endoplasmic reticulum by the
photoreceptor that in my schematic is
always highlighted by a yellow box a
solo cry2 is soluble in the cytosol
infused of fluorescent protein these
two's images here at the bottom of the
slides to show you the distribution of M
Cherry cry2 before light irradiation and
as you can see here the protein is
diffused in the whole cytosol of the
cell on the right panel in the wholesale
activation part you will see the effect
of the irradiation of the whole cell
with blue light and it will show you how
in this condition we can recruit the
protein on the whole surface of the ER
while the central panel will show you
the effect of the local delivery of blue
light in a small area of three by three
Micron inside of the cell with blue
light policies every two seconds
as you can see here in this image using
this system we cannot confine protein
demerization only in the small area of
light radiation as indicated by the
accumulation of the fluorescence of the
fluorescence in a broader area compared
to the light Aero radiation and this is
visible because in this case I use a
lookup tables but the fluorescent signal
grows from white to black when the
accumulation of the protein increases
so in this case the diffuse the the
recruited probe goes outside of the
error activation for two main reasons
first of all because the photoreceptor
is soluble in the cells and therefore as
soon as is activated in the air of
Interest it can diffuse outside this
area and interact with available binding
partner in everywhere inside of the cell
and this is a second reason is because
the switch of kinetic of the system is
relatively slow and the photoreceptor
can remain in its activated state for a
prolonged period of time a period of
time preventing us to achieve a very
high degree of spatial confinement
in the option to identify a more
suitable tool for this type of
application I decided to test the eyelid
system this system is based on the
interaction between two E coli peptide
ssra and sspp ssra is a very small Alpha
Helix that has been fused on the
c-terminal portion of the photosensitive
domain love to avabina sativa
phototrophin one this laptop domain is a
perfect photo Suites because a fun light
radiation it undergoes a dramatic
conformational change with the exposure
of the c-terminal alpha Helix and
thereby exposing excess array to this
binding partner sspb
this system as two main advantages over
the previous one first of all there are
several amortization pair with different
speeds of kinetic and some of those much
faster compared to the previous one and
in this case we use a system with a
switch of kinetic with an R5 of about 30
seconds and the second Advantage aspect
is that this system is functional even
when the photosensitive domain love2 is
settled to the membrane of the
intracellular organello be interest and
in this way diffusion of the
photosensitive element is more limited
because of the association to the
membrane so here again you see two two
images showing the distribution of the
soluble component of the diametization
system diffusing the whole cytosol of
the cells before light irradiation on
the right side you will see the effect
of the irradiation on the whole cell and
in the central panel the effect of the
local delivery of blue light as you can
see here with this system we can achieve
we can achieve a higher degree of
spatial confinement in a fraction of the
endoplasmic reticulum but still these
dimerization is not completely limited
to the area of light excitation because
also in this case the photoreceptor can
diffuse outside of the area of interest
and find its interacting partner that is
always available for interaction
I finally tested the magnetic system and
this system is interesting because not
only it has the same characteristic and
feature of the eyelid system with the
switch on end of kinetics in the same
order of magnitudes but because this is
the only Optical demolition tools where
both components are photosensitive
elements they must be contemporarily
activated by light to achieve the
memorization
so I also generate in this case a
dimerization system for recruitment of a
soluble protein to the endoplasmic
reticulum and as you will see here on
the right there is the effect of the
whole Cell Activation of the system so
with the recruitment on the surface of
the oliar and it is the center the
effect of the local delivery of blue
light policies in this small region of
interest and as you can see here with
this system we can actually confine
protein normalization essentially only
in the air of light radiation and this
is possible for the fact that since also
the soluble prey must be co-activated by
life to achieve the memorization we can
actually confine the amount of available
prey specifically in the area of
idomerization and as soon as both
component access this area of light
activation they are inactivated
so from this first first part of our
work we could conclude that all the
three-dimerization pair tested are
equally efficient in the modulation of
biological processes upon light
dependent activation of the whole cell
and the switch of kinetic is the feature
that defines the duration of the
intracellular reaction and this is the
parameter at which everybody should pay
the majority of the attention when
choosing a pair for a specific
application because the switch of
kinetic should match the dynamicity of
the intracellular reaction that you
would like to regulate using these tools
if you want to use one of the
dimerization's blue light emerization
system to confine protein memorization
in small subcellular volumes you should
choose a pair with fast on and of
kinetics where the photoreceptor is
functional when Tethered to the membrane
of the intracellular compartment of
interest and ideally very good control
the amount of available prey for
interaction in the area of Interest
so from our experiments the magnetic
system proved to be a very powerful tool
for the light dependent control of
protein demorization in subcellular
organelles however they're using
mammalian cells is limited by two main
drawbacks first of all this
photoreceptor requires a pre-incubation
of 20 degrees for several hours that
complicates its application in mammalian
cell lines and prevents completely it's
using mammal in mamas at all the other
drawback is that the diametization
efficiency of the individual
photoreceptor is relatively slow low so
we need to use multiple units of this
photoreceptor in order to release its
significant demolition
so we decided to team up with the lab of
Lauren Luger at General reserves campus
in order to engineer an enhance variant
of this admirization system in order to
create an ideal tools for application
and cell biology and ultimately in
mammalian models
so the magnet system was engineered
starting from the neurosporacross the
photoreceptor Vivid this photoreceptor
is extremely small is only 150 amino
acids and comprises two domain a
passcode that binds La Vina de Indie
nucleotide that is the photosensitive
moiety of the photoreceptor and another
terminal cap that is the region
responsible for the dimerization
when this photoreceptor is excited with
activating light in the end cap domain
there is the exposure of a stress of
hydrophobic amino acids that mediates
homodamatization of the two of two Vivid
photoreceptors the Sato group in further
engineered this dimerization tool by
introducing in one of the component
positively charged amino acid and the
other component negatively charged amino
acids thereby generating an
electrodamerization system
in order to improve these photo
dimerization tool we decided to combine
structure guided protein engineering and
cellular assay and in particularly we
used an assay to test all our magnets
variants they proceed the the capability
to recruit the soluble protein to the
membrane of the end to the motor
membrane of mitochondria
so this movie was a beautiful example of
our experimental assay where we could
see that before light irradiation the
soluble probe was diffused in the whole
cytosol of the cells and when the light
was turned on we can see the dramatic
Association of the solution protein
through the mitochondrial membranes and
when the light is done off we can see
the Rapid Release of the probe as well
so this type of experimental approach
enable us to make sure that we were
maintaining the preserving all the
positive aspect of the magnetic system
so low background before light
stimulation and efficient and fast
interaction upon my stimulus with the no
formation of homogeneous and fast
heterodynamic dissociation following
light offset but at the same time we
could select the magnet's pairs with the
new positive aspects and first of all we
optimize the dimerization interface in
order to increase the amortization
efficiency and increase the thermal
stability of the probe in order to have
a tool that was capable to function at
37 degrees and for this type of
mutagenesis the the strategy that proved
to be the most efficient was to think
was based on the introduction of
mutations that we identified in Vivid
analogs that are thermophilus ascomes to
the arascomicer they preferentially live
at 50 degrees
so as you can see here after our
engineering strategy we have been able
to identify several magnets marines that
you can see here highlighted in magenta
and orange they were characterized not
only by the faster on end of kinetics
compared to the original magnetic system
and they were totally capable to
damerize at 37 degrees without the
necessity to bring Kubota at 28 degrees
but also they were characterized by a
four to five times higher the medication
efficiency compared to the original
magnet system
so to summarize briefly some of the key
features of our enhanced magnet system
first of all is a tool that doesn't
require an exogenoscope factor to be
functional both components are extremely
small and only 150 amino acids it
doesn't homily commerizer for Aggregates
upon light irradiation and both
components can be fused at the NRC
terminals of a protein and are
functional when Tethered to the
membranes of intracellular organelles
we have engineered several pairs with
different speeds of kinetic and this
depends on one component of the
dimerization system that makes this pair
very versatile for application that
range of different temporal time scales
this system has a very low interaction
in the dark given the fact that both
molecules are photoreceptor and with
this system we can achieve a very high
spatial confinement of timer by using a
single wavelength of light activation
but let's see what type of application
we can develop by using this tool
so as I mentioned before this tools is
ideal to recruit soluble protein or
enzymes so the surface of intracellular
organelle as I showed you before we
could use this tool to recruit proteins
to the surface of mitochondria but we
wanted to expand the palette and soy
generated tools that enables me to
recruit protein to the surface of every
intracellular organelle so in the next
movie you will see how we could use this
tool to modulate protein agreement on
the surface of the endoplasmic reticulum
and in this case you will see how we
preserve the capability to confine
protein desmetization in a small
fraction of light illumination inside of
the cell at the level of the endoplasmic
reticulum as well
but we the the this system is so
powerful that we can recruit the
proteins not only at the level of broad
intracellular compartment but also the
level of the single individual organelle
as you will see here in this movie we
expressed in primary neurons a prey a
bait protein on the level of lysosomes
and then a reporter lamp one RFP to
visualize the lysosome inside of the
neurons simply delivering focal light at
the level of the license of Interest we
can recruit the soluble prey only to the
organelle of Interest
but can we beside recruiting soluble
protein can we really regulate
intracellular
enzymatic reaction inside of the cells
and the answer is yes so I was
interested in developing tools that
would enable me to modulate phosphine
acetites at the level of intracellular
membranes and the first application that
I developed was to modulate the level of
phospholip phosphatidylinositol for five
bifosphates at the level of the plasma
membrane in order to do that I fused a
five phosphatase domain to one of the
components of the Amax system
fusofluorescent protein to visualize its
distribution inside of the cell and the
other component was expressed in the
inner leaflet of the plasma membrane in
order to visualize pip2 inside of the
cells I use a reporter that is based on
the pH domain of PLC Delta fused to irfp
when I deliver blue light to the cells
the dimerization between the two emacs
components enables to recruit the five
phosphatase domain at the level of the
plasma membrane where the enzymes the
fines is substrate pip2 and the
phosphorylative 2 to pi4p and we can
visualize the reaction thanks to the
dissociation of the of the reporter for
people to the plasma membrane you will
see these experiments in the next in the
in the next movie the next movie will
show you the distribution of the people
reporter you speak to reporteries and
reached at the level of the plasma
membrane in primary neurons so before
the light irradiation as soon as the
light is done on that is highlighted by
the white dot in the corner of the movie
you will see the rapid dissociation of
this probe from the plasma membrane and
its accumulation in the cytosol when the
light is off you will see the rapid
reaccumulation of the probe to the
plasma membrane indicating the pfp2 is
resent either the plasma membrane and
this stimulation can be repeated as many
times as you want as we want because
this system is extremely reversible
one of the most interesting platform of
communication inside of the cells is the
is represented by sites of closer
position between the membranes of
different organelles so I was wondering
whether I could develop a tool that
would enable me to generate or expand
this platform of content some of
different organelles in order to do that
as you can see here in these image I the
ideas I expressed the two components of
my diametization system on the membranes
of different organelles in which I was
interesting in mediating the
dimerization upon blue light stimulation
the demorization between the two
photoreceptors would enable me to bring
in closer position the membrane of
different organelles thereby generating
stabilizing these uh the organelle
contact sites
this system is extremely powerful and as
you as you will see in the next movie
the first one will show you how we can
use these tool so to induce a membrane
contrast size between the endoplasmic
reticulum in green that Express one of
these component and lysosomes that
Express the other component that are
highlighted imagento as you will see in
the movie when the light is turned on
indicated by the white dot inside of the
movie you will see an increase in the
overlap between the two organelles that
is indicated by the Y the increase in
the white signal almond your Canal when
the light is done off we will see a
rapid dissociation of the two organelles
this is an average sample where we
develop a tool to induce the contact
side so between the endoplasmic
reticulum here in green and mitochondria
magenta
or for instance like in this case a
children's
hospital is using this tool to in this
context between the endoplasmic
reticulum and the plasma membrane as you
can see here where there we can see the
Harrow head upon light irradiation we
can see the formation of these enlarged
and most stable association between
these two organelles where we can really
modulate and study their dynamicity
so at this point after I prove that we
can really use this system for the rapid
and reverse modulation and generation of
organic contact sites I would I wonder
whether I could develop tools that to in
order to interrogate and study the
reaction that akura decides so far we
know that the most well characterized
reaction happening at these contacts are
the transfer of lipids and so I try to
generate a tool for the acute
manipulation of the intracellular pi4p
we are a constitution of an IR
transcology tester that I called October
this letter comprises two proteins osbp
osbp is a protein that thanks to a
speech domain can bind the membranes
where pfrp is enriched thanks to its
ffat Motif he combine the MSP domain of
a b a protein Express on the endoplasmic
reticulum and thanks with ORD domain it
can transfer pf4p from the Golgi members
to the endoplasmic reticulum where pf4p
is degraded in order to exert a light
dependent control over the stator I
express a soluble MSP domain of a b
fused to a fluorescent protein for its
visualization inside of the cells and to
one of the components of the
diametization system while I express the
other components of the surface on the
end of the ER
the MSP domain of a b maintains its
capability to bind endogenous osvp but
in the absent of activating light these
two components are too far apart and is
impossible for the SP protein to
transfer pfop across the membranes while
when we radiate with blue light the
system the dimerization between the two
emacs components regenerate the closed
proximity of this theater system
tethering system between the two
membranes of the AR and the Golgi and
you will see how in this case we can
actually activate the direct transfer of
the FRP from the two membranes
we can visualize the distribution of uh
pfrp thanks to a reporter rfpp4c and I
think that the next movie will show you
the power of these experiments and this
application so the next movie I'm gonna
show you two uh images on the left side
of the movie you will see the signal of
the MSP domain of a b before light
activation the signal is diffused in the
whole cytosol of the cell
and you will see an area of accumulation
in correspondence of the Golgi where
there is an enrichment of k4p because
this domain is associated with
endogenous ospp that is enriched this
membrane on the right side you will see
the signal Associated to
pf4p and this as you will see also f4p
is already accumulated
when the egg acid is the activating
light is turned on and this I Like It by
the white dot on the on the movie you
will see a dramatic Association of the
MSP domain of a b to the r in the movie
on the right side and the concomitant
reduction of pf4p on the Golgi in the
movie on the left these are so this
reduction and accumulation persists as
long as the activating light is
delivered to the system but when the
blue light is turned off you will see a
very Rapid Release of the MSP domain of
a of a b from the ER and uh and um and
the subsequent accumulation of the FRP
in the Golgi over a five minutes period
of time
foreign
was specifically mediated by our pospp
tethering complex we printcubated the
cells with hydroconut oil that is a drug
that specifically occludes the ORD
domain of osbp and in this case the Spy
deficient as you can see in the graph
here despite the efficient formation of
the the activation of October we
couldn't detect any pf4p transfer
in order to make sure that also we were
able to recapitulate the buffer B
function inside of the cells we
expressed these tools Alliance that were
Gene edited for the for the and didn't
Express the either papay or Babi the
cell line is known to have a disruptive
Golgi compass with the end of something
rich bpa4p we have been able to
efficiently express our tool in this
line and also in this case upon blue
light activation we could activate the
light dependent reduction of pa4p from
this ER and from these Golgi endosome
elements and after the pre-incubation
with heteroconazole again this lipid
transfer didn't happen anymore
we also confirmed that the dpf4p
transfer was specifically mediated by
the ORD domain of sppe because when we
induced the membrane tethering simply
using the pH domain or ospp without the
lipid transfer module we couldn't detect
any f4p transfer anymore
so with our worker we have engineered a
dramatically improved photodrama writer
pair that we call the nense magnets
using a combination of protein design
and cellular screening strategies that
can be broadly applicable to other
reagent optimization and I hope that
I've been able to show you how we have
thoroughly validated this iMac
constructs in a range of cellular assay
both in wholesale and local are
irritation conditions involving protein
recruitment different membranes interest
intra organelle Association and lipid
metabolism and trafficking
so I love open science so all the
construct that I show you today in this
presentation
um and many more are available on a gene
and please reach out to me in the case
you would like to use this tool for your
biological application
and last but not least I would like to
thank Pietro de chameleon Isla but here
where I perform all this work and this
particularly Anil and Andres your
babersdorf and then you buy Valentine
that they help me in the setup of the
microscope system for this type of
experiments and enable me in the
supporting with the mathematical model
to quantify the blue light dependent
confinement described in the first part
of this work and then I would like to
thank Lauren lugera janelian for his
outstanding mentoring in protein
engineering and you all for your
attention